[Music]
this place is beautiful like the perfect
holiday card it's no ads a lot it's like
this space of weather you can do a lot
worse than this place trust me
tell her that you like her
I've noticed this how spiders oh it's
not that easy you just have to tell her
you want the same relationship plus
boning hey what's up up good see you
downstairs when you found a bra
Christmas Eve bash come on come on boom
he's gonna break up with you you would
have to be the dumbest human being on
earth to do that like two dumber than
the people who blow on ice cream before
they eat girl and I have a thing have
you ever been with someone and you stay
up until like 4:00 a.m. just talking
about everything and you're just like I
can't believe I get to exist at the same
time as you know but like I'm really
happy for you
I realized that life is just a bunch of
stuff you can't control what is that a
bad thing
you think I happen good
but anything
[Music]
and she's hooking up with em no they're
not hooking up yeah
[Music]
just think your nipples bleeding
[Music]
[Music]